we are less than 24 hours away from more
clark county school district students
returning to campuses
grades 6 9 and 12 go back tomorrow after
more than a year of distance education
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in the newsroom tonight
with the latest on preparations for this
kristin sasha this is the first group of
secondary students
going back in buildings following the
return of pre-kindergarten to
third graders who started hybrid
learning on march 1st
now many high school middle school
teachers returned last week to arrange
classrooms
and just get ready for tomorrow students
have a choice of hybrid learning or
continuing full-time distance education
those in hybrid are split between cohort
a or b as you see here on your screen
cohort a is the group returning monday
and tuesday for classes
in person the district anticipates about
27
thousand students in total in grades 6 9
and 12 on campuses
this transition is welcoming for some
who rallied last month for schools to
reopen
a senior tells me it's an adjustment but
appreciates this opportunity
the idea of like going back and meeting
my teachers in person
like having conversations with students
my age
is exciting but i also just don't know
what it's going to be like and it is a
little bit nerve-wracking
campuses like valley high school here
set up the buildings with markers on the
ground directing
where people walk desks are also
positioned to accommodate
social distancing at sierra vista high
school the teens on student council
returned to decorate hallways
as well as to welcome back those
students this week hybrid students will
take
two courses in classrooms and then
finish their school day remotely online
a ccsd spokesperson says the district is
confident students will adapt to the new
schedule
which includes periods being an hour and
45 minutes in the morning
coming up at six more on the transition
and reaction from a teacher
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now
kristen thank you